hi i'm megan and in this video we'll
walk through setting up a class on khan
academy
first log in to khan academy once you're
logged in you should land on the teacher
dashboard
the teacher dashboard is the starting
point for most teacher focused
activities on khan academy including
creating and organizing classes
from the teacher dashboard make sure you
are on the classes tab
and then click the add new class button
in the top right corner of the screen
we recommend that you create separate
classes for each group of students you
teach
for example if you teach four sections
of seventh grade math we recommend you
create a separate class for each section
if you already use google classroom you
can import your classes with all
students directly to khan academy
if this is not the case start by giving
your class a name
a tip we hear from teachers is to choose
a naming system that helps keep your
teacher dashboard organized and easy to
find for both you and your students
a common trend is to use your name
class period and subject
now let's choose one or more courses for
your class
you can scroll down to see the full list
of courses available
you can choose the course by subject
such as algebra 1 or us history
or you can choose the course by grade
level like second grade reading or get
ready for 5th grade math
and don't worry if you change your mind
you can edit your class name and courses
at any time in the class settings
after you've set up a class you'll want
to add students and there's three
different ways you can do this
the first option is to use google
classroom
if you're a teacher who uses google
classroom you can link your google
classroom and khan academy accounts to
import your class roster directly
this will automatically send emails to
your students letting them know they've
been added to your class
the second option is for students to
join your class using the class code
each class created on khan academy has a
unique code which students can use to
join your class
students only need to enter this code
one time to be connected to your class
you can share the code with students via
email or by displaying the code in your
classroom
students can enter the code from the
teachers tab on their learner home they
will be automatically added to your
class roster after they enter the code
some teachers from the process of adding
students by class code challenging
especially those with younger students
but don't worry we have one more option
the third option for adding students is
to create accounts for them
please remember before creating accounts
for students in the united states khan
academy assumes that you already have
permission from parents or guardians of
students under the age of 13.
we do not recommend this option for
students over the age of 13 as it
creates a more restrictive type of
account
select the option create your students
accounts when you create these accounts
khan academy automatically generates
user names and passwords you are able to
create the passwords for your students
according to preference and we strongly
recommend you download the complete list
with login information to keep in your
files in case you need to consult them
in the future
one important warning you will only be
able to download this list when you
create accounts
you will receive an email with all this
information as well but you will not be
able to retrieve or edit this
information including passwords at any
other time
now you've set up a class and added
students but what happens when the class
roster changes
we know students move in and out of
classes during the year
to keep your student list up to date
select the class from the teacher
dashboard and in the left side
navigation select the students tab
from there you will be able to add or
remove students from your classes
if a new student is joining your class
click add new students and choose your
preferred method to add the student from
the three methods shared earlier in this
video
if one of your students moves from one
class to another but remains your
student select that student's name from
their current class and click on the add
to class option
from here select the class the student
is joining to add them to a new class
once that is complete remove the student
from the original class using the remove
from class option
in this situation you can move the
student from one class to the other
without the student needing to take any
additional action
if you are no longer a student's teacher
select the student's name and click stop
teaching
this will remove the student from all of
your class lists and disconnect the
student's account from your teacher
account
you will no longer have access to any of
this student's information
if you want to clear an entire class
roster like you might want to do at the
end of a school year select the box in
the first row and then click stop
teaching
this will remove all the students in
that class
many teachers recommend doing this over
the summer in an effort to clean up your
khan academy teacher account and prevent
the accumulation of students year over
year
one other rostering tip we'd like to
share with you all
khan academy's student rosters are
automatically alphabetized but student
display names often appear as their
usernames rather than their real names
as a teacher you can edit the display
name of any student by hovering over the
name you want to change
and clicking on the option edit display
name
type a new name save or hit enter and
you're done
this change will only occur on your
class roster it does not appear on the
student's home page nor will it change
the data they use to log on to khan
academy
now that you've completed the initial
setup for your classes we know you'll
probably want to adjust them in some way
during the school year
for any changes to the class you want to
go to the settings tab
here you can edit the class name
change the course or courses
update student sync with google
classroom
sign up for a weekly report on student
performance and even delete the class
we hope this video helps you get started
building your own classes on khan
academy
you